[Music]
good Harnett Davers watch this shot Oh
what's your shot oh I spent so much time
clearing out this area actually first of
all I got some news for someone sven
friend's boyfriend I have big news I am
married now
[Music]
you
that's right I married - what no we
didn't have a Minecraft wedding come on
we will have one in Minecraft as well I
promise okay I promise just give me
enough time listen they took a long time
to plan just this wedding yes yes she
will be your mom's friend oh it's so
great you're again
give me the brofist epic a lot of
changes a lot of changes I cleared out
this entire area it was a something I
probably shouldn't be spending my time
doing before a wedding but I also redid
the elevator for the meatballs so now
it's pretty cool you go through it right
yeah
now a lot of people have been saying
that the meatball has mold on it because
it's green now and that's just false
that's just offensive the meatball has
pesto on it okay that's right pesto its
pesto I guess now I can make it into
brown sauce I don't know if that looks
any better than what oh now I see
through the cracks that's kind of creepy
all right let me know in the comments
brown sauce or pesto smash like four
brown sauce and smash like four pesto
let's go gamers keep working wait
they're wearing headphones why are they
wearing headphones money you Trey the
money give me more money Council of
water sheep I got married what that why
is he read what happened how
how does that happen cancel of Watership
what is please bless my marriage uh-oh
cancel of waters it's trying to kill me
ah castle of authorship save me
they look it away causal of authorship
please please I'm sorry I should have
married in your church Oh God Oh God I
want to start off by doing a building
montage because I want to keep building
my Japanese house it needs to be done
right Sven's boyfriend
[Music]
man I really like how this is coming
along but I realize I put the ceiling
too far back I need to move it forward
but I think that's gonna look really
good let's see how my beautiful
villagers are doing today
whoa oh my god
[Music]
what oh gods are the the creepers so shy
he's like Oh God
I can't believe it's done this did they
kill anyone did they touch you thank God
oh thank god hey you can sell me bells
so yeah as you can see I increase the
size of the slave chamber I mean the
house of epic people one day it's gonna
pierce through the ceiling and enter the
skies make oh god there's only two left
oh they escaped very well I feel like I
should extend the Frick chamber it needs
to be bigger right yeah we're thinking
that yeah it needs to be bigger are you
guys ever pleased are you guys never
happy huh I bring you into my beautiful
house I give you freak chamber love me
the next person that says hmm he's gotta
get lava dipped
Oh who was it oh sorry I didn't need to
click oh you didn't see anything our
goal right now our last thing to do in
Minecraft is to defeat the Ender Dragon
the last boss of Minecraft won't you
once you defeat the Ender Dragon it's
game over the credits roll and it's all
over so one thing I'm told by you guys
is that if you feed a bank what's up if
you feed oh I'm sorry yeah I will feed
you you feed a fox a diamond they will
find you a treasure he took it Bengt go
forth find me treasure
give me what I eat this lasagna so yeah
today we really have to prepare for the
fight against the ender dragon I want to
grab a sign and I want to put ranch they
sudden you guys suggested Bengt show me
the treasure god damn and then there's
another suggestion from you guys
supposed to put birch lasagna because
it's a birth sure tree bank stop wake up
we need to fight the ender dragon
banging
beg wake up ha ha oh my god please am I
seriously gonna have to drag Bengt
[Music]
where's it going lead me oh my god did
you guys hear that you follow the
treasure back well well well it looks
like I found you I have a frost Walker
my boots in case you're wondering what's
happening so you got sucked in here
you try to escape how is that possible
everyone kept saying that Dinnerbone ran
away because all my pets died wishes
there's a line okay
oh my god Dinnerbone please come back
stop running away from me you love me
remember none of my pets died I wouldn't
hurt a soul
hey guys hey Joey it's done look who's
back
oh yeah look who's all tickly yeah
that's my date about right there mate
and my name Emma thanks for finding the
treasure Bank what a Deadeye boat stop
that looks really uncomfortable God then
a bone I swear to you that I closed it's
closed maybe I should build like an
aquarium for dinner bone Stephano
I haven't used the new texture pack in a
while
okay that's epic I'm surprised you
remember thank you so very cool oh man
hello spits hey you need help fighting
ender dragon like cringing and laughing
at the same time it's alright let's get
some sand Milton oh my god there's
meatballs in Minecraft
Oh delicious thank you Oh someone's
knocking on my door new merch arrived
look at that very epic oh maybe here we
can put an aquarium well we can make a
whole aquarium out of it that'd be sick
that's exactly what I just said
yeah well it's it'd still be epic oh
there's gonna be epic
forgot the power of my shovel oh wait
here's the wiring oh yeah I try to I try
to build a paper farm here it didn't it
didn't pan out my god
it feels so good to you know getting
married is epic and all but it feels
good to be it was such a amazing day it
was the best day of my life I know it's
so cliche to say that and when I
whenever I heard other people say it I'm
like that's cringe it was such an
amazing day everyone my family was there
my just family was there my close
friends were there I've only seen such a
good mood everyone was just happy - it
was so beautiful we've been planning it
for like over a year
and so much it's a lot of stress to fly
the wedding I just wish I knew that it
would turn out so amazing because then I
wouldn't have word about a single thing
because it could not have gone more
perfect that's just so happy I'm so
happy
[Music]
now you cannot go in aquarium should I
make it bigger okay enough of that lame
it's all about gaming okay this is the
most essential part of defeating the
ender dragon okay oh is it possible to
just build a giant bucket and put the
ender dragon in it or is it possible to
put the energy dragon in a boat all
right it's done I just need to fill it
with water oh oh oh oh all right all
right all right not bad
give me suggestions for how I could
change the design of that because it's
so ugly please help me oh my god I have
frost Walker okay okay so what do I do
maybe the frost Walker no what if I walk
it yes and then I can place it here oh I
think we did it I think it's done oh man
then the bone is gonna be so happy
dinner bone loves water then their bone
more like new home look how excited he
is yeah aren't you excited little did Bo
flip-flop flip-flop he loves it
I don't know how to get him out of there
no don't know it's van van get up Oh God
not here it's been eat no don't kill him
don't kill em I'll kill em go get up no
not here please please see this fat eat
eat eat eat Sven Oh God
Oh smell you turn you don't understand
you don't understand what you have just
died
Oh God Sven intense boyfriend just went
through the portal don't do it stop
panicking stop panicking it's fine no
panic
keep freaking keep freaking everything
is fine I will protect you the Frick
chamber will never be lost the friction
bar will be protected at all cost if my
name isn't what are you doing I'm sorry
if I your boyfriend in your son he
literally went through the bar at all
oh it begins but we are not afraid
spend spend it get out of there oh my
god please please get out of there
spread yeah yeah good job Sven guys stop
Oh God protects the font wait I have the
baby wait I got a change back okay here
we go
don't worry kids and keep you insane
save where is Sven Oh No Bengt don't be
scared
everything will be all right he's
terrified there he is my man Oh
[Music]
yeah I make them fight each other oh my
god so traumatic
Sven where are you oh my gosh man okay
it's about to get spicy they've won a
text event ah oh my god no no no no no
no that's bad
I will protect this city no matter what
the car
[Music]
can you tame those that be so fake
I'm gonna try it okay it doesn't work
I've got home is dying I got to stay
alive for spent Oh God
I got to keep living for play right the
pigs have joined the pigs have come to
save us the pegs are fighting will it
turn oh god oh my god spenders crazy oh
god the pigs know this is not the way
you spend ice this is not the way spend
I keep eating oh god this is so scary
spend please said eat you can eat as
much as what oh god the power of pig I
thought it was gonna die Oh God
[Music]
do something dinner boat oh my god oh he
doesn't see me because I'm wearing the
helmet that's all nevermind nevermind
old but the ship give me strength gives
me power they're too afraid to even come
near me oh my god is riding a chicken a
[Music]
cooked chicken Jase I know what's there
she please I'm not testing your strength
oh my god they're on top of them a bomb
[Music]
like a great man once said you picked
the wrong house
on top of what their shoes made I will
go on top oh god oh god oh god this is
bad idea
girl god I'm gonna die Retreat retreat
the power
want to save me we did it yeah the coast
is clear
[Music]
we defended Broll and we stood our
ground nothing can stop us right banked
epic rule everything you did so good
like God
Sven you did the best to sort of a mom
I swore to protect you and that I did
now keep freaking like you never fracked
before Frick in front of your child I
don't care do what you must
fortune three on sale very well now
they're giving me discount on now you're
giving me discount huh
what about when you needed me he took
some vanished in me
Sven I forgot your boyfriend getting the
bucket guys they just ran right through
ahaha that's out yeah is that raining
again
no are you kidding me before I used to
wait days actual days for thunder now I
get two in a row oh okay I want to get a
creeper head then creep but oh man you
guys showed mercy to child
okay so we supercharged a creeper and
then we let the that's a skeleton horse
oh god oh my god what that oh wait
no supercharge it supercharge one no not
two not two and then we just got to make
sure these guys blow up first no no head
die oh wait yes we got it yes so how
come some have as a Gloria on there
that's so cute
okay this is actually super rare where
is it here's the horse oh my god oh god
oh god no I kill the horse dang it don't
kill the horse Felix you idiot okay okay
just gotta make sure I don't bear this
yes you're mine does that work
yes I thought for sure you didn't need a
Saito but I guess you do doing their
bone Hey
oh my god don't kill my hairs then their
bone got a girlfriend that's out now
Frank did I tell you to stop working
never stop working ever see I'm not
gonna wear this one cuz this when gets
scared if I wear this one spend it does
approve of this one now for our battle
with the ender dragon the last boss of
the game are you serious they there's
the thing I want to show you guys you
know in the beginning you guys tricked
me
Oh cute oh god I'm scared
all right good night you tricked an old
Minecraft veteran so now I'm gonna do
what everyone told me to do in the very
beginning of this series
another Felix yeah well guess what this
time I'm gonna do it on my terms
blast protection baby didn't even feel a
thing
oh god I'm on fire eat the meatball ate
the meatball that's how we're gonna kill
the Ender Dragon baby with beds now
before we beat the ender dragon we need
to assemble our army I won an army are
you kidding me I won an army of snowmen
I want to spend there I want Jurgen
there or you cannot be serious
okay yeah I want to do this hey guys
we're gonna go ice skating yeah yeah
[Music]
yeah they love it they absolutely love
eight
I'm so happy guys you got it go a little
quicker
it's like a bajillion things you can do
this game it just never ends thanks for
taking over my beautiful place what in
the world are you doing stop stop that
Oh Council of what there she Oh council
of authorship why why can't sell
photoshoot what did I do to make them
there's a point at some midnight
ice-skating for you guys beautiful damn
Dinnerbone way to be subtle dude so
apparently if you let a skeleton guy
kill a creeper which is what I'm trying
to do here
Oh God they have a chance of dropping
are you kidding me so yeah I think
according to you guys skeleton man has
to kill hey it's me creeper it's a lot
trickier than it seems
oh yeah this is how you want it yes hit
him once oh god don't blow up dang eh
okay well there's a lot of things to hit
here maybe I shouldn't have this helmet
on
yes keep shooting them yes keep shooting
them come on Oh it happened it worked
yes yes DJ cow play that okay so jukebox
this is now a face of Grande all right
what song is this all right we'll play
we'll play that once we beat the game
and this range is stopped you want this
yes my queen I mean my king yeah my
queen sure why not my queen Fifi Popo my
queen we made a promise that we were
gonna defeat the Ender Dragon together
and I intend to keep that promise we're
gonna beat the ender dragon together
we're gonna finish
the legacy of Legends go forth to my
child
got bought
go through
faster my queen faster yes with enough
beds and enough courage and enough speed
we will outnumber the Enderdragon don't
be a god I hate these oh my gosh
be careful
Beibei Bobo
baby Bobo
[Music]
that's it for this episode smash like if
you enjoy check out the hundred million
club merch represent that comedy by epic
epic see you guys next one bye bye